and now ladies and gentlemen I have the
privilege in presenting a bright new
star who literally burst across the
Hollywood sky from the footlights of
Broadway last year her third picture a
little thing called gentlemen's
agreement she hit the jackpot she is
here tonight to present the award for
the best performance by an actor in a
supporting role ladies and gentlemen
miss Celeste Hall
thank you Bob I remember so well how I
felt last year sitting out there
trembling excited and hopeful and
finally overwhelmed with gratitude so
far be it for me to prolong the suspense
the nominees for the best performance by
an actor in a supporting role are
Charles Beckford in Johnny Belinda
Warner Brothers Jose Ferrer in Joan of
Arc Sierra Pictures RKO radio Oscar
Homolka in I remember mama RKO radio
Walter Huston in treasure of sierra
madre warner brothers sessile caloway in
the luck of the Irish 20th Century Fox
and the winner is whoa
Oh Bob said you can't take any credits
I'd like take a credit myself how many
years ago many many years ago I raised a
son and I said if you ever become a
director or a writer please find a good
part for your old man